we're going to turn now to the chaotic
situation at Twitter after the site's
new owner Elon Musk gave employees an
ultimatum work extra hard or quit many
chose to Walk Away Now sources tell
Reuters that the company's offices are
closed until Monday Jonathan Vigliotti
has more
Elon Musk appears to be taking a Gallows
humor approach to Twitter's latest
troubles Thursday night posting an emoji
of a skull and crossbones followed by an
image of a Twitter tombstone he also
tweets how do you make a small fortune
in social media start out with a large
one
but for many employees it's no laughing
matter this cell phone video appears to
show a scroll of insults aimed at Elon
Musk projected against Twitter's San
Francisco headquarters Twitter's an
unstable company right now and Zoe
Schiffer is managing editor at the
investigative Tech newsletter platformer
she says earlier this week employees
were given an ultimatum either pledged
to high-intensity quote hardcore work
with long hours by five Thursday
afternoon or resign with severance pay
shiffer says many more workers than
expected decided to leave in 10 seconds
stop even going online to count down to
the deadline seven four three two one
happy New Year hundreds of people have
said they are out and a lot of those
people were working on core
infrastructure projects to keep
Twitter's site reliable to keep it
secure and to keep user data private
Schiffer says so many employees left the
company didn't have enough staff to
figure out who is still working and
needed to shut down its offices and cut
badge access until the dust settled
they're very scared that employees are
going to sabotage the service on their
way out the door
and despite the trending hashtag rip
Twitter shiffer says Twitter is probably
not facing an imminent collapse but she
says when there's high traffic and fewer
workers to fix those problems Twitter
could become glitchy or difficult to log
into and those frustrations she says
could be all it takes to lose lots of
users Gail
uh Jonathan thank you very much this is
sort of one of those hashtag hot messes
this can't be going according to his
plan and the employees now are very
angry it seems how do we know that that
isn't his plan we have no idea why he
chose to buy Twitter and what his
intentions were essentially you say that
because he was tweeting this morning hey
we've had more engagement more traffic
in the last 24 hours than before you
know so you look I think it's important
to note there's a lot of conversation
even though not everybody in America is
on Twitter most people on America are
not on Twitter correct but politicians
use it they are news people use a lot of
conversation starts on Twitter and then
pops up on television in other places of
course and when journalists I think
about this like how long can we keep
using it as a legitimate Source if it
continues to devolve into the chaotic
situation that it is what's next right
no doubt about it well said
also I just can't believe that's the
plan
but but you raise a very interesting
point you know Elon does not run away
from controversy no he doesn't he leans
in sometimes he stirs it up he leans
into it